-♪♪ Virtual Reality Pictionary ♪♪
-First, we're going
to need partners,
and we've found some good ones.
[ Drum roll ]
Joining my team, you know her
from "Saturday Night Live"
and she has a new movie
called "Ferdinand" coming out
next Friday.
Please welcome Kate McKinnon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, c'mon.
Can you get cooler
than Kate McKinnon?
-Good to see you. Hey.
-Can you get cooler?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tariq's partner tonight,
from the new SciFi show "Happy!"
Give it up for Patton Oswalt,
ladies and gentlemen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm feeling good.
Welcome.
Now, the game works
exactly like Pictionary,
except the person who is drawing
will be wearing one of these
virtual reality headsets
right here and drawing
in 3-D space using
a program called Tilt Brush.
We're going to be able to see
their point of view on
the big screen upstage.
45 seconds per turn.
I will go first.
You guys can all take
your seats.
You guys sit there and
you sit there, my pal.
All right, here we go.
What number shall I choose,
you guys?
[ Audience shouting "four" ]
That's weird.
Everyone said --
Everyone said four.
Isn't that weird?
[ Laughter ]
All right, here we go.
Four it is.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
-Yeah, you might want to wait.
-Yeah, I can't see if I --
Did any one see?
Oh, you're not guessing.
You're guessing.
Oh, no.
All right.
-Oh, Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, I won't let you down.
I'll try not to.
-C'mon, Jimmy.
-I don't know, man.
I don't know.
I don't know but this is --
This is an object.
-Is it English?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, it's in English, yeah.
-All right.
-Wait, okay, wait, where am I?
Okay.
Tariq, don't do
anything weird, man.
[ Laughter ]
I swear I'll get you back, man,
I really -- don't do anything.
-Jimmy, look out!
-Stop.
[ Laughter ]
All right, ready?
-Yeah.
-Here we go.
Line, hanger --
Christmas tree.
Oh, a man --
a man with a snowman --
A hat man -- a hat --
a man with a hat --
And he's -- oh, gosh.
He's on a mountain.
A man with a hat on a mountain.
[ Laughter ]
He's the cow man --
He's an elf on a cow?
Yes?
[ Cheers and applause ]
An elf on a shelf?
-Yes!
[ Music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-Legs up, legs up!
-Wow.
Wow.
-Legs up!
Patton, you're up next.
Here you go.
-I'm up next?
-Yes, you are up next.
This is the headset.
-Oh, man, you did great, Jimmy.
-That was great!
-Wow.
-All right, good luck.
You know how you do everything?
-And they pick a number?
-Yeah, the audience will choose
a number.
[ Audience shouting ]
-I go it, thank you, no.
They all said six.
[ Laughter ]
-I got it.
-All right.
-What?
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, here, I'll hand you
the thing.
I'll hand you the thing.
-Yeah, okay.
You hand me that thing.
All right.
Here we go.
-Anything is possible.
-Oh, yeah.
Hang on.
Put this on.
Oh, dear God.
[ Laughter ]
Wait, wait.
-Wait, I'll give you this.
And the trigger is --
starts the painting.
-Oh, that's right, that's right.
Okay.
You got me?
-Yeah.
-All right, go.
[ Laughter ]
No, stop it!
-Banana! Banana!
-Yes, yes, yes, okay. No.
-Banana boat.
[ Music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-How did you get banana boat?
-That's how we do it.
-That's -- dude, that was
a confidence right there.
That was great.
-That was terror.
-Yeah, right, it was just
pure terror.
Kate, you're up next.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah.
You know how to do this.
This is good stuff.
-All right.
-Alright, what number for Kate?
[ Audience shouting ]
-Okay, okay.
-Okay, draw the number.
Draw the number -- I'm sorry.
Get the number first.
I don't want to see it.
You look at the --
-Oh, shoot.
-Yes.
You don't have to wear
that yet, Kate.
-Oh, I don't know, Jim.
-Which one did you choose?
-One.
I chose number one.
-All right, we are number one.
-Oh, man.
-Kate, we're going to get this.
-Kate.
-I really have to say that
I don't know. Okay.
-Kate, you look so cool right
now, I can't even tell you.
-Oh, wow. Thanks.
Okay, great.
-Yeah.
-All right, here we go.
-Okay, got it.
-Yeah.
Okay, here we go.
-Okay.
-Okay, the moon, a pie?
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Okay. Okay.
All right.
Okay. I have no guess.
A walnut?
[ Laughter ]
A walnut, spinning walnut?
An olive?
In a martini?
A -- Is it the Earth?
-Oh!
-The Earth rotating?
There's people looking --
pointing at it.
Super moon, super moon.
-No.
-No, point at the moon.
-Oh, no.
-Don't point at --
Don't point at my walnut!
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Pointing at the
spinning walnut.
-Disco ball.
-Disco ball, yeah!
[ Band plays ]
Tariq, thank you for the help.
That was really well done.
-That was!
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
-...hang from a string, but yet,
you had a string coming up
from the bottom which is --
It's a little different, but --
very, very
interesting disco ball.
Hey, Tariq, thanks for the help.
It is your turn.
There's the headset there.
You know how this works.
Any number.
What number, guys?
[ Audience shouting ]
Ten is not a number, guys.
One through nine.
That was good.
That was good!
-No, it wasn't good.
-No, it was good.
-I tried to draw the people.
-No, it's good.
I saw the people
doing the dance.
-Got it?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-Do I say -- I say what it is,
right?
-Well, kind of, yeah.
-Okay, it's like a --
like you do it.
[ Laughter ]
It's an action.
-An action.
-Like you do it.
Like you do it.
Oh, my, ridiculous.
-Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
Oh, Christmas tree?
Decorating a Christmas tree?
Trimming a tree?
[ Band plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's so silly.
Trimming a tree and banana boat.
Okay.
It is time for the final round.
It's going to be a showdown.
Okay, here's what's going
to happen.
I'm going to draw.
If Kate guesses the clue first,
we win.
If Tariq or Patton get it,
then they win.
-Okay.
What number?
I'm just assuming -- five.
[ Audience shouting ]
[ Laughter ]
-What is it?
-It is a phrase.
You ready, pal?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Great.
-I'm feeling good about it.
-Okay.
Here we go.
And -- Here we go.
-Okay.
[ Light laughter ]
-A cow --
No.
-Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Sorry, sorry, where am I?
-Wow.
United States.
-Oh, my gosh.
-The country --
-Take the bull by the horns?
-Oh, my God.
Here, wait, sorry.
Take the bull by the horns?
[ Laughter ]
-Taking the country by storm!
-Um --
-What the --
-Oh, Jimmy.
A donkey.
-Jimmy's having a seizure!
[ Laughter ]
-The elephant in the room.
The --
-A halo on a donkey.
-Halo bull?
Bull in a China shop?
-Cosmic cow.
The cow jumps over the moon!
It's a spotted cow!
-Holy cow!
-Yes!
[ Music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
- That's it.
-Oh, was that it?
-"Holy cow" is what it is.
-That was it?
-That was holy cow.
-Did you say it?
-Oh, my God.
-I didn't say it.
-You are the champs,
right there.
Tariq, Patton Oswalt,
the champions.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a nice guess.
My thanks to Kate McKinnon,
Patton Oswalt, Tariq Trotter!